whether you like to call them zombies
walkers undead or infected i think we
can all agree there are menace so grab
your controller or your mouse and
keyboard and let's chop off some heads
in this video we're talking all about
dying light 2 where to go what to do and
how to make the most of your play time
so that you're ready when this type of
apocalypse happens in real life for more
dying light 2 videos make sure you're
subscribed to gamespot
in dying light 2 you play as aidan
caldwell a member of the pilgrims who is
headed to the fictional city of villador
on a quest to find his sister mia in
order to do that aiden is going to need
to run and fight his way through
villadore and that's where dying light
2's skill tree comes in handy this list
of abilities is broken into two sides
one for combat and one for parkour both
sides have 24 skills each that aiden can
acquire to make himself more worthy of
taking on the city's ever-present and
ever-growing challenges the only way to
unlock these skills is to earn points
points that are also separated by the
categories of parkour and combat this
means that you won't be just earning a
general skill point and placing it on
whichever side you'd like luckily these
points are pretty straightforward to
earn because you get them by simply
doing the activity running and jumping
around will earn you experience in the
parkour branch and progress you towards
that skill point similarly fighting
enemies will progress you towards a
combat skill point this xp gain is
normal during the daytime but
successfully making it through the night
time when things are more dangerous
gives you a bonus in xp gain so what
skills should you invest in first well
the answer to that depends a little bit
on how you plan on playing dine light 2
but let's briefly dive into each branch
and talk about a few of my favorites
early on
similar to the first dying light stay
human puts a big emphasis on traversal
providing you with parkour abilities so
that you can make your way through its
desolate urban landscape quickly and
effectively the difference here is that
the parkour gameplay has been expanded
to be more natural and intuitive to
learn as mentioned earlier there are 24
parkour skills for aiden to acquire the
first of which is high jump from there i
recommend grabbing active landing
because not only is taking fall damage
very inconvenient for your health but
it's also very unattractive to break the
flow of a good run after that i'd say go
for firm grip during my playthrough i
chose far jump and regretted it because
i'd often run into situations where i'd
go for the big gap come close grab the
ledge but fail to hold on due to my lack
of stamina with firm grip you can still
recover and get up onto that ledge even
if you're completely tired saving
yourself from the grip of death
the other half of this fight or flight
tree is of course fight the first of the
24 combat skills is vault kick which i
rarely found a good opportunity to use
but it's required so you don't have a
choice in getting it or not from there i
recommend grabbing perfect dodge which
slows time for a bit and staggers your
enemy when you dodge at the right time
after that i'd say go right below it and
unlock perfect parry which essentially
does the same thing as perfect dodge but
this time it's for when you block at the
right moment both of these skills are
great defensive tools to have when
fighting both humans and infected and
the brief slow motion can help you get
your head on straight if battles get a
little too hectic and while we're on the
subject of dodging and blocking don't
forget to dodge in the beginning of my
playthrough i was constantly forgetting
about this and only blocking and
parrying sometimes the game will remind
you to dodge when facing heavy attack
throwing foes but even for the more
simple baddies don't forget to move out
of the way and once you've got some good
defense going you'll want to grab power
attack in dying light 2 humans can learn
to avoid your moves if you go for the
same attack too often during a fight
power attack allows you to switch things
up while also chopping off a bigger
chunk of the enemy's health an overall
good tip for figuring out what to unlock
is to look at what comes next further
down the tree and shape your decision on
how you think you want to play
what i love most about dying light skill
tree is that it is less expensive than
some other games with similar
progression what i mean is skills do not
cost more than one point no matter how
far down the list you go the first row
costs one point and so does the last row
so you don't have to save up points in
order to grab a move that you've had
your eye on if you've met the
requirements for that row you can grab
that skill these requirements include
your health level which affects the
combat branch and your stamina level
which affects the parkour branch both of
these levels are upgraded using
inhibitors stay human describes
inhibitors as drugs that are produced by
the gre the global relief effort dying
light's humanitarian organization and
they enhance your body's abilities as
well as your immunity to the virus
in order to reap the benefits of these
devices you'll need to find more than
one three inhibitors equals one upgrade
to either your health or your stamina so
where do you find them inhibitors can be
found in crates often hidden inside gre
quarantines and gre anomaly locations
both of which fall into the category of
night activities this is because lots of
infected hide inside buildings during
daylight hours effectively making the
gre quarantine buildings a hotbed for
activity until nightfall the monster at
the anomaly is pretty much the same deal
inside during the day but outside and
available to fight at night however
these aren't the only ways to nab
inhibitors as some can be found by just
exploring off the beaten path these
crates can be in a room with no doors
that need to be picked and only one
sleeping infected to sneak past
requiring much less of a fight to obtain
and don't worry the game notifies you
when you're within 50 meters to a crate
and displays how close you are to
getting it in order to steer you in the
right direction you should prioritize
these whenever possible that way you can
achieve higher health and stamina much
faster and you'll set yourself up to
grab whatever skill you want when you
have the points for it one of the
fastest way to get your aiden skill
points is to not skip stay human's
additional content this includes side
quests day and night time activities and
challenges for example completing
something like a military drop can net
you 1 000 experience for parkour get you
an inhibitor and even a resource needed
for upgrading mods something we'll get
into a little later mainlining the story
quests can be great if you're on a
mission to rush through the game before
elden ring is released but if you want
to really experience some of stay
human's awesome abilities i'd recommend
you take the time to gobble up those
additional xp opportunities but you
won't get very far in any of the game's
quests or activities without weapons and
armor
and stay human you'll mainly be swinging
different types of one-handed and
two-handed melee weapons these are maces
hammers and sticks that cause blunt
damage as well as axes and machetes that
deal slashing damage there is also a
ranged category with crossbows but those
seem like they'll be harder to come by
each weapon you find or buy has its own
rarity like common uncommon rare etc and
even though weapons can't be upgraded
they can be modded in three different
areas tip shaft or grip the first two
usually add elemental damage to your
weapon such as fire or electricity grip
mods can do things like make your weapon
heavier so it inflicts more damage mods
can also prolong the life of some of
your favorite weapons when their
durability gets low so maybe hold off on
filling your newest weapon with mods use
it for a bit wear it down and then give
it a second life by adding some fire to
the tip
when it comes to gear dying light 2 has
4 different class types to choose from
brawler ranger tank and medic however
because you're not choosing a class at
the start you're not locked into any
specific kind of gear this means you can
mix brawler gloves with a pair of tank
shoes and a ranger mask this type of
variety and setup can work well and i'd
suggest you having different armor sets
at the ready for different types of
quest objectives for example want some
extra buffs in the stealth category slip
on some ranger gear want quicker health
regeneration for a fight slip into your
medic gear have fun with it and similar
to weapons gear can't be upgraded
however unlike weapons gear has no
durability and no mod slots so what you
see is what you get wear it or sell it
and speaking of selling things feel free
to sell off all the valuables that you
have laying around in your pockets you
won't need them for anything else there
is even an option to quickly sell all of
them at once you can find out what
button it is on your controller of
choice by looking at the lower right
hand corner of the screen while you're
selling for chances to find really good
valuables to scavenge you should be
exploring the dark hollow night
activities forsaken stores are another
nighttime opportunity but in these
you'll find crafting parts something
that you shouldn't be selling
the first thing i want to say about
crafting is to loot everything if you
see a bag a trash can or any other
searchable object you should be digging
through it and stay human you'll be
crafting lock picks medicines various
types of boosters and more these items
are crafted from blueprints that can be
further upgraded using craftmaster
resources these resources include
different types of infected trophies and
military tech one aspect of dying light
2 that i found painfully slow is the
healing nothing's worse than being right
at the end of the healing process
getting that final blow to the head and
dying that being said medicine was the
first blueprint that i upgraded as soon
as i had the right amount of resources
and i'd suggest you do the same
now that we've gotten through what i
consider to be the big stuff let's talk
about some additional ways to be more
productive in vilidor for starters have
a destination in mind at night as i
mentioned the world of dying light 2 is
more dangerous under the moonlight and
if and when you alert a howler and a
chase breaks out you're going to want to
know where to go so early on i'd suggest
unlocking as many safe zones as you can
and keep the closest ones in mind when
you're out and about trying to take
advantage of that nighttime bonus xp on
a similar note be mindful of the
suggested character levels for the
region that you're exploring don't get
caught in a level five to six area when
you're just a little level two aiden you
don't have to memorize the map but just
pay attention to where you're running
and finally don't forget to use your
binoculars to uncover locations around
the map a little faster this might seem
like common sense but i also forgot they
existed shortly after being introduced
to the feature so be better than me and
whip out the binoculars every once in a
while especially if you're high up
and there you have it all the
information you'll need as the new kid
in vilador according to techland dying
like 2 has 500 hours worth of content so
let us know in the comments if you'd
love to see more videos about the game
and in the meantime go watch our review
of stay human to see what mark delaney
thought of it like this video if you
enjoyed it or found it helpful and stick
to gamespot for all things gaming
you